weil ich bin mittlerweile das soll sich
jetzt auch nicht arrogant einfach mal so
aber auch so viele airports wie hahn
jemand gefressen oder so vielfältig
scheitern da ist doch einigen landkreis
gehört click the world auf dem video ist
herzlich willkommen zu einem neuen video
ja aber ich hoffe natürlich euch geht es
gut bevor wir anfangen muss ich mich
erstmal ganz kleines bisschen aufregung
weil ich bin heute extra früh
aufgestanden extrem oder was heißt
extremsten also so acht uhr früh dafür
ist nicht früher ja ist normal aufstehen
und angenehme situation
jetzt denkt nicht dass ich immer lange
schlafe aber ich schlafe schon manchmal
kann so bis 9 halb zehn uhr ich mache
auch dann abends immer länger also
wirklich so manchmal sitze ich da bis 1
uhr morgens zwei uhr morgens und steilen
und irgendwas oder mal jemand andere
deswegen kein held jetzt bitte auf jeden
fall bin ich so früh aufgestanden dachte
mir ich solle mir haben so viele leute
geschrieben alex wiegel bringt neue erbt
muss raus so fading ich habe wirklich so
viele fotos bekommen und in diesem
prospekt stand also auch online
und da dachte ich mir ja gut fährst du
morgen erst mal kurz im laden die sollte
jeder haben weil auch online bedeutet
für mich dass es die auch im laden gibt
und dann bin ich hingefahren gab es
nicht ich gucke online was steht online
online ausverkauft wo soll ich dir jetzt
kriegen sie sind einfach weg wenn wer
bestellt denn morgens die kommen
irgendwie um 24 uhr 1 ins tor direkt
ausverkauft das ist erwartet denn auch
so dumme kopfhörer
wir verstehen ich na gut dann bin ich
wieder zu action gefahren da wollte ich
auch welche haben ich war in dreiecke
teams eine ausverkauft und dann hatte
ich eigentlich kein bock mehr auf hinter
heute ich habe mich so gefreut auf den
ganzen tag und dann habe ich tipps
bekommen wo leute meinen kaufmann hat
auch welche und ich sogar ich war mal zu
kaufmann hier guck ich mal vielleicht
haben die ja welche und tatsächlich
wirklich ein ganz neues modell haben wir
heute blaupunkt wireless keyboard ich
muss sagen ich bin sehr gespannt ich
habe allerdings schon gelesen tws 10
steht drauf das heißt alte bekannte
allerdings
ein neues modell sage ich mal also ich
könnte mir auch gut vorstellen
das ist das im internet für zehn euro
gibt vielleicht noch weniger schutz vor
was ich bei kaufland für gezahlt haben
20 29 99 deswegen das sollte das wollte
ich jetzt erst einmal direkt machen im
internet zuschauen wie teuer die dinger
denn eigentlich sind obwohl wir
eigentlich auch cloud punkt drauf steht
und das ist ja eine renommierte marke
also laut punkt kennt man ja eigentlich
von diesem radius und so also also ich
habe jetzt jeder seite gefunden
chinesisch für da gibt es für knapp 10
euro 9 eur 77 also ich weiß jetzt nicht
ob es das gleiche modell ist es
irgendwie schwierig zu sagen könnte auch
nicht so sein ich glaube allerdings dass
es vielleicht wirklich ein produkt von
dieser marke blaupunkt ist weil ich
könnte mir auch nicht vorstellen dass
die sachen aus china bestellen und dann
ihren namen drauf schreiben obwohl man
weiß sollte aber auf jeden fall deutsche
beschreibung und so weiter dabei sein
deswegen würde ich sagen wir werden
sehen ich habe dir jetzt hier auf
anderen seiten auch zum beispiel gibt
sie für 23 euro bei ebay
all das sind halt diese standarddünger
i10 tws ich weiß nicht ob ich das kann
ich nicht sagen sonst bestelle ich diese
idee ist einfach auch mal und dann
gucken wir ob sich das ähnelt demnächst
irgendwann weil was man ja wirklich
sagen muss wenn lidl da irgendwas
rausbringt so bluetooth kopfhörer ich
denke wir können wirklich was ob das für
diese kauften sich jetzt aufhält weiß
ich nicht die gibt es auch wirklich nur
exklusiv bei kaufland ich habe die neben
woanders gefunden ja und da haben wir
auch schon das produktbeschreibung wo es
für c ladekabel danach dingen für
samsung und co und hier dann die
airports in anführungsstrichen natürlich
aber natürlich alle ans original
angelehnt und ich muss sagen auf jeden
fall
solche hatten wir noch nie also das ist
mal was neues das unglaublich steht auch
auf den kopfhörern ist ein blauer punkt
recht
also ein bisschen anders ich bin jetzt
mal gespannt
ich hoffe dass finger diese woche noch
in das war die neuen airports protesten
die originalen für knapp 300 euro
ob die ähnlich sind weil hier die haube
geht ja so ein bisschen runter
das haben wir ja bei den airports der
ersten und zweiten generation die hole
ich mal kurz nicht so hier habe ich
meine airports und dass man kurz zu
vergleichen
an sich relativ ähnlich das ist ein ganz
kleines bisschen größer
gut im letzten test hatten wir die 1000
ews das waren bis jetzt die besten haben
gut abgeschnitten meister sound und
jetzt bin ich einfach mal extrem auf die
sich ja gespannt auf die besser sind das
wäre ja wirklich katharina in meinen
videos ich bin so total eigentlich ein
richtiger helfer mittlerweile von diesem
ganzen schrott den hier irgendwelche
discountern zu verkaufen einfach weil
die preise brutal erhöhen und man diese
produkte an sich wenn fünftel im
internet bekommen deswegen an sich bis
jetzt noch mein tipp für euch wenn ihr
euch in günstigen ersatz suchen wollt
geht die 1000er es gibt es auch sehr
vielen verschiedenen seiten einfach mal
googeln müssen wir noch irgendwas
vergleichen was sagst du kurz einmal die
kopfhörer vergleichen auf jeden fall
deutlich kürzen also um sich deutlich
kürzer links reicht die airports großen
beispiel sind ja auch ziemlich kurz
geraten jetzt also die gehen hier
anscheinend schon ein bisschen mit der
zeit haben sich auch von der robusten
und so ist dort ähnlich ein bisschen
länglicher gar keine ahnung also bis
jetzt gibt es nichts zu meckern ich
würde mal sagen das einzige was wir
jetzt machen können worauf wir ja auch
alle wartet soundcheck mikrofon check
distanz check und dann war's auch schon
achso und vielleicht auch die labels
charting haben das haben wir jetzt auch
hier integriert letzten zwei gestellt
haben sie nicht das hat einige tausend
erstens braucht ja alles klar dann hole
ich mir mein handy raus dann willkommen
wenn das ganze ich setze mal eben ins
ohr ja irgendwie hier merkt man schon so
ein bisschen also die bestehen brauchen
die bestehen sie auf hab so billig
plastik also er fühlt sich sehr billig
an du kannst du ja mal selber in ordnung
dann merkst du glaub ich was ich meine
ja ultra holte
das fühlt sich viel zu tun weiß nicht
also bin ich ja ja willich gilt es sich
jetzt wenn man sie ins ort vom case
überhaupt nicht wenn das finde ich bis
jetzt das hochwertigste das sage ich
irgendwie jedem video ja immer dass
irgendwas hochwertig ab sondern drückt
noch mal den knopf zum koppeln irgendwie
habe ich ein bisschen das gefühl die
sind leer
kann das denn sein muss man dir sagen
weil eigentlich dürfte es ja nicht so
sein alle elektronischen geräte sollten
aufgeladen sein wenn sie dann vom käufer
gekauft werden die leute herzlich
willkommen zurück
ich habe jetzt ein bisschen geladen und
wie man sehen kann hier blinkt was so
roth tippt man sieht man nicht
hier kümmern und hier auch ist ja auch
egal also viel bling da nicht das stimmt
aber man sieht dass irgendwas jetzt
angegangen ist
und ich muss auch ehrlich sein ich habe
gerade ein bisschen die beschreibung
durchgelesen und hier ist es anders
man tut die einfach ins ohr laut
beschreibung dann kommt auch irgendwann
soundtrack so der gehst du doch das ist
der sound der dienstort und jetzt
sollten die hier bei den bluetooth
geräten auftauchen tun sagt tws 10
verbunden zeigt kann man hier also
sofort ins knie ich bin begeistert ja
machen als erstes den soundcheck ich
habe eigentlich immer ganz lustig wenn
man einfach nur mein gesichtsausdruck
sie ohne irgendeine musik im hintergrund
und ich der einzige bin der jetzt
irgendwas offenbart hat 321
am anfang dachte ich es super dass voll
schwierig das ist ein anderer sound aber
es klingt jetzt auch nicht so dass ich
es ok kann man sich gut geben willst du
auch einmal ganz kursrally 321 im sommer
kein guter song bislang nur dass er kein
guter start für die von den 1000 t
werden noch viel viel besser
ich würde sogar noch mit behaupten dass
ein fast eine der schlechtesten recht ja
ja ja
der sound ist so metallisch das klingt
einfach nicht nur musik aber anfang
dachte ich aber noch als es geht
angefangen hat so dass er da hat sich
eigentlich in ordnung angehört ja du
hast recht also die etw ist 1000 mal
besser
christa für das gleiche geld sogar noch
ein bisschen weniger glaube ich im
internet hat man keine idee ja wir
können auf den ultimativen test holte
irgendwas von dahinten
die frage ist was den kopf dann kriegst
du die krasseste soundqualität und das
dann mal vergleichen ja gut ja dann muss
ich sagen das ist auf jeden fall das
schlechteste von allen bildern er klar
also deutlich besser natürlich aber das
ist ja auch ein großes headset so weißt
du da sind ja nicht so klein ja oder wie
auch immer man das in europa sprachen
and drop wir machen wir mal kurz im
distanz test und dann rufe dich noch
einmal an ok basteln hier aber für 30
euro ist frechheit die armen leute die
das kaufen und ich glaube auch wirklich
nicht dass die von lidl oder action oder
sonstwo besser sind die kriegen dualen
hörschaden leute kauft oder scheiße
nicht hört auf mich und kauft euch das
was ich euch empfehlen weil ich bin
mittlerweile das soll sich jetzt auch
nicht arrogant anwender so aber so viele
erben und zügig aber niemand getestet
oder so viel fähig scheiße da ist doch
niemand weiß für kids in the world auf
dem video ist ja
ja klingt noch mal was soll ich dir
jetzt kostet ja klingt absolut okay
schau nicht bereit war
ich finde es voll okay also man versteht
sich super ist alles in ordnung
deine stimme auch klar dass ich jetzt
auf dem kopf bekomme ich wieder klar
mikrofon und noch ganz kurz distanz
check angegeben sind die mit zehn meter
wir gucken mal so ob das auch wirklich
hält also an sich muss ich sagen auf
jeden fall nicht die besten werden schon
deutlich bessere checkt die ganzen
anderen videos ab allerdings besser als
die von tedi und als sie von kik sowieso
das war ein kompletter reinfall
trotzdem empfehle ich euch weiterhin
kauft dieses heiße nicht die 1000 ews
legal ans herz mister zwar zwei wochen
warten bis sie dann da sind wenn ihr die
mittel stellt aber da macht auf jeden
fall nichts mehr falsch
sie werden trotzdem auf meinem account
verlost ich mache jetzt gleich wieder an
der story ihr muss auf die antworten und
dann gewinnt die irgendwie kriegt
informieren nachrichtenkanal activity
glocke wir sehen uns morgen 19 uhr
wieder gibt's neues video haut rein muss
ich noch ich muss sagen das war's